that makes me good at Josh Bannon from
quarries
thanks for having me this is a really
this is a really weird talk for me to
give well first of all because I'm
definitely not going to give a talk of a
differential privacy frankly the primary
reason for it is essentially everyone
that I'm funding to do differential
privacy research has already spoken or
will speak and so the idea of me kind of
trying to tell you what somebody else
has done when they're the expert and are
talking about it for an hour is like on
the order of terrifying for me so I'm
not like that that's just not gonna
happen
and so I'm gonna construe this rather
broadly I guess so two different pieces
of background if you're not familiar
with DARPA its DoD is kind of department
defenses kind of high-risk high-reward
research the kind of tag line is
preventing technological surprise
the idea is we try to do research in
technologies that we believe will be
transformative and then I guess the
second part just by way of background
about myself so I'm a cryptographer by
trade and then I was at RAND Corporation
for a couple years doing cybersecurity
policy analysis so I guess it's kind of
a fun place to be where we fund research
so okay this is cryptography this might
as well say privacy I hate it when
people use these things interchangeably
but I just did so fine we basically done
we've been doing programs as regarding
in the kind of privacy domain for about
I'm gonna mess this up but something on
the order of 10 plus years we started
with procede which talked about
computation on encrypted data safer was
actually built a lot of the pluggable
transports for tor or started some of
that work I shouldn't say you know we
did them that it was a whole kind of
thing but it was all about doing
Brazilian communication over the
Internet
Brandeis is about building privacy where
systems safe where has something to do
with software obfuscation I just took
that one over this week so it's been
kind of fun and that was actually why I
was I was really hoping to be here for
the whole week but we had RPI meeting
for that Monday and Tuesday and then
race is about a new program that I
started about a security student
messaging in contested Network
environments think country scale places
where it's hard to communicate and so
I'm not really going to talk about all
of them I'm just going to talk about
these two though now that I kind of
understand all the work that we're
funding under safer I should point out
that Dan Boneh
as part of safer has done some
incredible work in privacy there's a a
work called prio
which is about how do you do mushiya
kind of basic statistical analysis on
encrypted unencrypted web browser
telemetry information that has been part
of typed in firefox and hopefully we
will actually see wider use in Firefox
and then another one and mess us up is
fidelia's which is got accepted at
Oakland for this coming year and answers
this kind of wonderfully paranoid
question as to how can I prevent malware
on my computer from doing key logging
for logins and passwords and what they
literally do is they put Hardware
between your keyboard and your computer
and between your computer and your
monitor raspberry PI's and as you do
keystrokes that literally it assumes the
presence of a secure Enclave like SGX
and pretends that sjx is secure and it
what it does is it encrypts your
keystrokes as it leaves the monitor and
then forwards it directly to the secure
Enclave up to a different place in the
cloud where the website can then access
it and then it actually hacks the HDMI
signal to decrypt it on the back end and
then actually show it up on your monitor
which is just kind of awesome just for
those of you into that kind of thing and
I am so I'm really excited but those two
works I'm not gonna talk any more about
them today and so really the point is to
talk about some of the work will we do
in Brandeis explicitly not all of the
differential privacy work which is
substantial so you know if you hear
Akron or Michael weird room I can't
believe I'm gonna actually try to name
all the names or Katrina or Christine
and I'm definitely failing or dawn all
of you know parts of their research are
funded under our work and the really
really exciting work at that so I'll
talk a little bit about what race is
intended to be and then quite frankly
what I'm most excited about talking
about today is about the future and
where we should go and the tagline for
that is I'm Brandeis is ending in a year
and I'm desperately trying to figure out
what
what we should be doing moving forward
so okay
okay so what is Brandeis Brandeis is you
know can you have your cake and eat it
too like it's really about building
privacy where systems so can I actually
can i empower user to make the decisions
they want about privacy can I build the
systems that actually implement a user's
desires as regards privacy and kind of
how far can I get we're organized
everything at DARPA is organized around
like technical areas or TAS basically
think of that as kind of research
focuses that anyhow so ta1 are kind of
these underlying privacy-preserving
techniques so specifically differential
privacy and secure multi-party
computation or computing unencrypted
information we do human really excited
that were doing some really awesome work
in human data interaction so just
because you say you want privacy doesn't
mean we have any earthly idea about how
to implement it we have to have a real
communication my favorite story for that
is back in the day when especially
Android users would download the
encrypted messaging app signal it would
say you know I need your contact
information and a lot of people who
download signal are our privacy aware
people and they're like why do you need
all of my contacts this is not a thing
that I'm going to give you the reason
that signal needs your contact
information is to be able to very
quickly infer who it is that you know
who else is using signal but they don't
say that right so like how can we need
to be able to build mobile applications
that very very quickly inform you what
of your data they are using and why they
are using your data right so that's
research that we're currently doing
mainly at Carnegie Mellon we are
building three different experimental
integration platforms which is basically
to say three major use cases coalition
information sharing mobile mobile
systems on mobile phones and what's the
third oh yeah Internet of Things really
smart buildings we're gonna talk more
about that I'm super excited that you
heard Sherrod speak yesterday so I don't
have to kind of I think that built a
certain intuition about what we're
dealing with in that space and then
we're trying to measure privacy which is
just insanely difficult because it's
really hard to define privacy a little
and measure it and so I'm probably I
don't even think I'm going to begin to
talk about that today
so okay so one of the things that we've
done is
actually kind of well the name is at the
very least motivated by NSA developed se
for Android security enhancements for
Android this is privacy enhancements for
Android we've basically developed a
version of the Android operating system
that is explicitly designed to in a very
fine-grained fashion control how
applications gain access to private
information on your phone so these
things are called pals you're always
forgetting what it stands for it's
something like privacy privacy
assistance layer I always I never
remember it but the upshot is it
basically anytime that an application
wants to access you know one of these
things it has to go through this and in
particular if you haven't given it that
access they won't get it and it will
catch if a application is trying to gain
access in a way that was kind of
untoward interestingly the other option
is we can actually turn off access
beneath an application so Google might
want your so an application might want
your location and you have the ability
using this to say no which i think is
kind of fun so yeah this is running on a
phone right now which means it's kind of
real and actually the team that's
developing this which is BBN into six
labs have been really impressive in
their ability to track current Android
updates as they occur in fact some of
the more recent versions of the Android
operating system are actually make it
easier for us to do to do this okay
so that's just one version and I really
I think that's I really hope this kind
of gets adopted in some fashion our goal
is to open source this and frankly our
real goal is I would love if Android
actually released versions of this okay
so this is another thing we're doing
this is UC aid stations on the left a
person has a particular ailment they
need to get right into an aid station
can I do this while keeping the actual
nature of my ailment encrypted can I do
this while actually keeping the various
status status status 'as of the aid
stations encrypted and the answer is yes
and we can do it in there it is
so that that's fun I'm just kind of
basically showing this is kind of like
my bag of tricks I'm just kind of
showing like various things that that
we're doing just to kind of give you a
sense of the nature of the work that
we're
optin so which of the programs that use
is all Brandeis so yeah so everything is
yeah this is Brandeis is it's a very
large program I think we have oh I'm
gonna mess this up it's 15 different
major performers I think is what we have
and then associated subcontractors so
it's four and a half year effort we're
at our three and a half year mark I'm
not supposed to tell you how much it's
funded for but epic FOIA death so you
can look and see so yeah so this is
something that gets that so this issue
of kind of when you ask people why you
want their data CMU has come up with so
let me back up there's something that I
always love calling the MIT Pizza study
and I just googled it and actually it's
actually real basically a bunch of
researchers Stanford economist in fact
went up to a bunch of MIT students and
said we want the contact information on
your phone and the students said no or
some percentage of students said no and
then they said okay we'll give you pizza
now now will you give it to us
and the answer was 50% more said yes
which means that like what it basically
means is that our are kind of we say we
want privacy but our barrier for like
giving up that privacy is embarrassingly
low in some cases and so how do we
actually do better human factors
measurement of what it really means for
it to be private so one of the things
that CMU is actually doing so this is an
example of a study they've run and
they're running a number of other
studies like this as part of their
scilab they've actually they basically
track people all the time peep
participants obviously waiting
participants paid witting participants
and when you show up at a coffee shop
you for instance get it seems like
you've walked into the la prima expresso
business cafes like this have started
used surveillance cameras with anonymous
face detection software the software is
capable of estimating the number of
customers in line in order to optimize
operation like how okay with you of this
and the idea is that instead of just
kind of asking you this abstract
question it actually waits until you're
in the place where these kinds of things
occur and then present you with a
realistic scenario and the idea is to
try to drive the realism bet to a better
more realistic response they actually
also pay you if you answer faster so
like if you answer they're they'll pay
you more than if you answer at the end
of the day kind of thing
so that's kind of one way we're trying
to get around this kind of contextual
issue I will say one of the so they're
about to run a fascinating one I guess I
shouldn't scoop them so I'll just say on
an emerging technology and what I'm what
will be fascinating is actually to see
the responses change over time because I
would imagine in the first couple of
days people are simply going to be like
I had no idea this was possible and then
once they realize it's possible their
answers are going to be different so
that will be kind of interesting all
right so that's been in the mobile
domain I'm going to talk now about the
coalition information sharing domain so
this is just kind of one of the things
that we're doing is trying to figure out
flexible ways of letting coalition
partners reason about how exactly it is
they want to share information you know
and I'm honestly not going to talk too
much to this I don't know how that this
is kind of neither here nor there I
guess the purpose of this audience but
this I really like in the sense that
imagine you have 26 countries with 10
different ships and they want to they
want to park at Park at 10 different
ports for the purpose of giving aid to a
country and what they don't want to
reveal is the location of their ships
the speed of their ships the
displacement all that other fun stuff
and so how can can they do this kind of
collaborative route allocation and so we
can do that in I think it's like seven
seconds again this is for those you kind
of familiar with the notions of MPC the
way to think about this is what we're
trying to do is take not terribly
academically interesting cases of MPC
but implement them in in real settings
to try to actually make a difference and
that's really where Brandeis has been
trying to do yeah okay so right that's
kind of what it looks like there okay so
and then we get to the we get into the
work that sherrod is doing over at UCI
and that team associated so I should
mention of course that in each of these
settings what you kind of have is so
what Sharada is is essentially an
integrator so in other words they've
developed this architecture for IOT
analytics and then we have a number of
performers who are working to try to
privatize that including some folks in
this room so in particular it turns
that they can use Wi-Fi handshakes to do
social network so geo-located social
networks so who's with whom and when
and they're deploying this pretty
broadly around the UCI campus so I love
that the kind of main initial
application for this was how fast can I
get a cup of coffee on campus did
Shradha already talk about this yes no
okay so in particular you can see where
are you
by virtue of looking at the the Wi-Fi
handshake so you can figure out how many
people are at the your particular coffee
place
therefore how packed is it and so it can
kind of route you to the right place
given real-time analytics as to how many
people are actually there this raises a
number of privacy questions in
particular who's with whom and when is
that totally have with us the the
semantics of the data is unchanged with
regard to whether or not it's us in this
room right now or its students in a dorm
room at 2:00 in the morning right
there's no difference in terms of what
that data says but the underlying
privacy contents of that data can change
and normally enormous lis right and so
how do we begin to think about what that
what that means it is kind of one of the
things that I think sure odds work has
challenged us with so that's another way
of saying that the privacy value of big
of large data is very hard to infer just
that a semantic level I'll give you
another example so we just recently
started funding a professor here at
Berkeley who is a great guy we walked in
he said not that it matters so he's a
great guy or not I just said that
whatever but the we walked in that and
he and we asked what his research was
and he said we're improving access to
microloans in the third world which is
what he is doing and in particular in
part specifically in Africa essentially
the main infrastructure they have is
mobile phones cell phone infrastructure
okay so we and you know like think of
like m-pesa if you're familiar with that
kind of that kind of technology so what
they want to do is be able to give
microloans one of the issues associated
with loans in general is credit scores
and so what he figured out how to do was
how to infer he can infer credit ratings
via social via cell phone metadata
so that's an example or well for that
matter actually and it's like
country-specific
but you can basically use machine
learning to do that and he's
demonstrated this in a number of
countries that's an example of data that
has a certain amount of value or a
certain amount of privacy content and
then by virtue of analyzing in a
different way is shown to have a
different content that we had no idea
was possible and so how do you deal with
the underlying privacy in in these
settings I kind of have like a a lot of
these stories at this point and that's
really where we are right being able to
do Wi-Fi handshakes cameras we can infer
thing I mean mental health status
Carnegie Mellon University is currently
using cameras in some of their
classrooms to infer how many students
are sleeping during lectures but but
that data can be used in any number of
ways and the notion of consent or
utility is very complicated in these
settings where you know it may be that
you know they only ever intended to use
the data in one way but do you do any
number of kind of information sharing
agreements or other kinds of things that
could have completely broad implications
than any and in a number of other ways
right and so this is kind of what we're
facing I will say some of the work that
Sherrod has done which i think is really
cool is securing data at that kind of
scale is really difficult so we're we
are figuring out how to apply
differential privacy to this kind of
string data setting how to even do in
kind of bulk encryption and whether it's
possible to do processing on this
information while it remains encrypted
as you can imagine that's pretty hard to
do though I don't think it's impossible
okay so those are kind of our three mini
areas let me tell you about two
different other things that we are
currently doing so one I'm really
excited about in the sense that I'm not
funding it but it means that it's
actually been used is so in other words
like the best thing about DARPA
sometimes like when we develop
technology and someone else actually
wants it right because that's like
that's our main win and in this case a
non-profit who I don't think I can I can
name but has basically hired yahwah to
do so for instance if i wanted if i want
to do better policy related to juveniles
right and i want to for instance
understand what the relationship between
juvenile mental health and juvenile
incarceration is that would mean I have
to have access to both pieces of data
depending on the state you're in or just
generally speaking co-locating those and
that information is complicated so what
if I could take the information encrypt
it and then run the computation on the
and to basically create encrypted act
like create aggregates which we then
decrypt but I never actually hold the
individual information so that's the
thing we basically speaking we can do
they are doing it I because the
contracting isn't fully finalized I
should say I have another there's
another team that will be doing that and
they'll be on contract in like three
weeks also doing it for child
specifically this is a state that has
like an on the books legal requirement
to do an analysis on how they treat
their children how like the state treats
the children but again they also have
laws that state that they cannot
co-locate information and so we'll be
using encryption to try to figure out to
try to solve that problem and so put
another way I think that in at least
some cases these kinds of kind of home
morphic encryption solutions can be used
to do better policy based analysis again
the other way to do this of course is to
make sure everyone has all the access to
all the things that's certainly a way
that you could do it that is hard for a
variety of reasons that I think a lot of
people in this room appreciate here's
another one we're looking at the state
of Virginia and trying to look at how
outcomes related to their college system
so in other words what's the value of a
college education in the state of
Virginia in order to do that you kind of
need to co-locate a lot of information
about salaries and loans and all sorts
of other fun stuff that's hard though
not impossible to do as is the least one
person in this room who's doing it
completely unencrypted which is awesome
but so we're trying to again do this
over encryption here's just like our
random smorgasbord of all the different
technologies we're kind of underlying to
do this scale mama is an open-source
tool to do secure multi-party
computation we're doing some work on SGX
I'm really excited that we're also doing
some work in something called sanctum
which is a Shawnee devadasis doing it's
like an open source a secure Enclave for
risk
five architectures functional secret
sharing is cool in the sense that it
it's a very specific technique that lets
you do updates to extremely large
encrypted databases with the size of
only a couple of AES encryption so
that's it's kind of a for those who
would care it's it's like it's a really
hard thing to do and that's it's an it
enables us to for instance update an
entire encrypted map within like Kilian
kilobytes which is very very hard to do
so I'm not gonna go over all the DP work
I believe a lot of this has been talked
about I don't even know why I put local
VPS like its own bullet point but I put
these slides together and not enough
time
so okay yes and this is just one example
of the open source tools that we have
there are there are many others all
right
so that's that let's talk about a
different program so this is about
privacy but in a very different way so
this is like more closer to the privacy
as confidentiality how much can i lock
down information given a particular kind
of use so race is about second clearly I
need to mute something okay race is
about could we use cryptography and
obfuscated communications to build an
anonymous and attack resilient mobile
communication system that can reside
completely within a what we are calling
a contested Network environment again
think here country sized area so the
idea is so just to step back tears an
amazing technology tor is tor kind of
relies upon Satori's an ability to
anonymous anonymously access the
Internet and it relies upon thousands of
volunteers distributed globally and it
kind of gains its resilience through its
living kind of everywhere the problem in
with tor is that it has to announce
where it lives you know and so and and
because it announces where it lives
countries block it so there are not so
there are many countries where tor
essentially speaking does not work and
so what we're trying to do is to try to
basically say okay fine could we
actually just build a distributed
presence completely in you know some you
know lockdown environment that actually
doesn't know enough about itself to be
targeted
and yet is able to do the most basic
functionality which is messaging so
we're not being nearly as a kind of we
don't think we can do internet scale
that actually internet access that's
much harder especially because it
involves like session ization which
which would be pretty hard to block from
a net flow perspective or to obfuscate
so so roughly speaking imagine you have
a bunch of guys who are your you know
folks who are just volunteers and then
you have Alice want to send something to
Bob and the rough idea is that not just
that the the message itself will be
encrypted so and an encryption
thankfully is is a essentially a fact on
the ground right now but the address C
will also be encrypted and the system
will compute on the encrypted address C
in order to figure out how to route it
to that address C using a secure
multi-party computation a very as
lightweight as possible secure
multi-party computation and so yeah this
is all about it would be really cool if
you built this highly distributed thing
but if it if it's rolling like custom
crypto it's gonna get spotted a mile
away and they'll just block it right so
how can we do this in such a way where
it's actually not blocked so that's the
kind of two main tasks
yeah only that our security properties
are pretty extreme in the sense of
end-to-end encrypted messaging full
metadata security and ideally
unobservable an unobservable means if
you're not actually sitting on a system
running it so if you're not like
literally on a phone that's running this
or on a on a network node that's running
this you shouldn't be able to infer via
just kind of looking at its
communications whether or not it's
actually running this system because
that's about the only way I can think of
that this might possibly work in
difficult places
yeah so that it's basically broken up t1
is going to do the underlying
cryptography th you will do the
communication links t3 will be their
actual integrators and we're building
our we have a separate team building out
a large-scale testbed in order to try to
figure out whether this is actually
going to work so on this kicks off in
May we hope contracting is currently in
place I'm not going to say too much
about this other than the goal is
essentially to do a thousand party
secure multi-party computation at scale
over hidden communication links over ten
specifically 10 Mbps links which is
aggressive so we'll see we'll see
whether we can do it again our hope is
that because the underlying
functionality is so basic in other words
you basically are just parsing where is
it trying to go and how do I allocate so
it's essentially coin tossing not much
more than coin tossing and then it might
actually be possible that that kind of
scale we'll have to see am I on Titan
okay okay so what what is what is coming
up so I like it as open as possible in
terms of the things that we're doing and
I this is a you know I'd like to take
you the first to hear this but I've been
telling this absolutely everyone the
program that I'm building is on
something called zero knowledge which is
a oh god saying this in her - avi is
kind of funny but ok the the idea that
basically how do i how could I prove to
you something without revealing the
underlying encrypted inputs right so in
other words can I prove that I know a
secret key without saying that can I
prove that I have a certain monetary
value or anything on that order you know
so how you know that that's kind of
that's been known that we can do this
since the 80s I kind of coming at it
from it from a bit of a different place
which is well ok there are two different
things first is that the last five
issuers have seen extraordinary growth
in zero knowledge technologies largely
coming out of crypto currencies and
those are think of those as low
complexity very high rate zero knowledge
proof what I'm interested in is far more
complex and therefore slower so like can
I do really complicated things in a day
so as an example
could I reason about software and zero
knowledge could I give a zero knowledge
proof of security or insecurity in zero
knowledge could I a lot of this stuff
I've been thinking about is so two
different other you may use cases one
I've been in a lot of rooms where people
talk about fake news and all they want
to do in life is to lock down all of the
like for every piece of information on
the internet I want to know where it
came from right that has like
extraordinarily bad implications from
from a kind of freedom on the internet
scenario right if someone takes a
picture of a protest we shouldn't be
able to know who that person is right
necessarily at least so can I give zero
knowledge proof of integrity of digital
information without actually revealing
and you know information on I I think I
think is a it's not like a we don't need
zero knowledge proof to do that but
their knowledge proofs could be a very
important tool to do that kind of thing
um the other is actually how the
government kind of communicates about
things that it does so as an example you
know the US government said that the
North Koreans hacked Sony and then there
was a company in the Bay Area that said
no we think it's not them could the US
government give us zero knowledge proof
of attribution right and before you
think that's the craziest thing ever
realize that cyber command right now is
actually tweeting virustotal commits
that they're making for advanced
persistent threats and so it's not the
craziest thing in the world that like
the US government would actually release
kind of some some kind of highly
technical information for the purpose of
verification we're they're kind of sort
of doing it already so so basically the
the basic structure of this program if
it happens and let me be clear it may
very well not happen it happens all the
time that program managers have dreams
that they're that our director is crush
so basically area one would be actually
building NP statements so in other words
take complicated things in the world and
describe them in a way that I can give a
zero knowledge proof so that's not
really a creek that's not really a
cryptography task it's really something
broader like complexity theory or
programming languages it's something
more and I think it should be really
interesting anyhow most most
cryptographers will just say given given
a proof statement how do I prove it so I
want to ask how
actually save the proof statement that's
part one okay fine part two is how do I
actually prove it efficiently and then
part three if I have anything to say
about it which I may not is actually
blue sky like theoretical zero knowledge
work so you know things like
probabilistically checkable proofs
founding better cryptographic stuff on
like post quantum assumptions so like
learning with errors is a common
plausible you know post quantum
assumption okay so that's area one I'm
gonna skip consensus protocols because
not because I don't think it's
interesting actually it's really
interesting it's just not really about
privacy
the tagline here is I think that bitcoin
is essentially an existence proof that a
cop that economics has a place and
distributed computation so basically how
can we rewrite our understandings of
distributed computation to get beyond
you know malicious and honest but
curious into notions of utility which
kind of sort of already exists in basic
forms in cryptography but I want to lock
cryptographers in computer scientists in
a room like sorry an economist in a room
and create new distributed computation
frameworks so fine that should be all
kinds of fun for any number of reasons
all right so this is like a terrible
slide but I'll try to talk to it so so
basically I mean so this is you know
Brand X is going to end in a year and so
I didn't create Brandeis I took it over
John launch burry created a Brandeis in
fact I'm actually the fourth program
manager in two years for that program
which is super weird but only because
two of them had like really great things
happen to them and moved on and so I
just kind of was you know the guy they
brought in but the question kind of is
you know what you know what should DARPA
role in privacy research be and so I
kind of want to start that these
thoughts in kind of two different two
different places the first is that our
role is really to be transformational so
if it sounds like it's evolutionary if
it's kicking down a particular you know
if we're just kind of you know we know
we can do a thing and let's just push a
little further that's really not what
DARP is here to do that that's not our
purpose you know so it's really that
what is the thing that totally might not
work that we could do and the other is
it you know the one thing that Brandeis
isn't really addressing because it's
really hard and we were never set up to
do it is privacy and big data
and so that's kind of what I've been
thinking about in terms of where we
should go and I have two different
thoughts and then I'm probably gonna
leave it to see yeah man this slide
really doesn't say anything so the two
things I've been think so
the underlying kind of the thesis is
that we are living in a persistent
surveillance environment right now
everyone is collecting all of our data
all the time and their can and they're
sharing it and computing on it in ways
that are both expected and very
unexpected in ways that are not
adversarial at all in highly adversarial
and it I just would claim as a I guess
just I would claim that it is
essentially impossible to measure the
underlying privacy content of the data
that's collected about us and so there
are kind of two different paths I think
we could take one of which is much more
likely than the other so the first path
is how do I simply cut off the data flow
so in other words how do I empower the
average American to be a digital ghost
in a big data world could I have a
mobile phone that was perfectly useful
and yet perfectly invisible to those who
actually collect the information about
it I think I think it's technically
doable but hard and I'm not sure if it's
doable in a foundational way which is to
say we might have tools to do it today
but then it's kind of like a tit-for-tat
in terms of other large companies we'd
probably figure out ways to defeat it
and then you kind of have to go back and
forth but its enormous the important
both at a societal level and frankly for
the US government oh yeah I should
probably say the second thing about
where this is coming from I think we're
really getting to a place where privacy
is not just about you know Oh someone
you know knows my social security number
and they really shouldn't someone knows
my health and they really shouldn't you
know it's like that sucks for me I think
where we're getting to is there are
countries in this world who are using
the same technologies that we think of
in a kind of ah shucks way for like
country scale social control like this
is occurring right now it's specifically
in China and so I think that
you know what it has been an important
area is only getting more important and
I think darpa role is to combat those
uses you know and into to retain to let
someone have because it's we're getting
beyond a place where like my ownership
of my data is now not just an issue of
you know you know something about me
that I don't want you to know but you
have actual leverage over me in in a way
that I'm not okay with
so like teachers in some American states
being having to wear fitbit's so that
their health insurance knows what
they're doing you know that's just the
start of it you know think of all of and
I don't mean to be like sitting up here
and like you know mr. McCord ever but
you know like think of the work that
Sherrod is doing at a at a at a large
scale and then used to infer things
about you and then kind of especially
when you build it into a like a social
credit score which then becomes a whole
host you know so privacy is about making
sure that those inputs well one of the
things that privacy is about is trying
to retain ownership over your inputs
into this larger system okay so that's
where the kind of need to cut off the
data comes from I honestly I just can't
imagine we're gonna do it but it would
be fun to think about if you don't want
to you the other aspect of that is again
so so if we make this claim that we
don't understand the underlying privacy
content of information the thing I do
think we would understand is the privacy
content of queries right so I may not
understand you know the kind of global
value of you know global privacy value
of data but I might understand its local
value with respect to some query and so
what if we could build a system that
essentially I think it's like you're AI
angel on your shoulder basically build
build a capability that actually resides
with data owners that essentially
represents you
right and so when when someone wants to
access your data within you know and it
within some data center it has to
contend with this kind of semi
interactive functionality which is to
say its interactive with the data owner
and its semi interactive with you
so you upload it you give it certain
privacy preferences that you want it
represents those preferences to the data
owner frankly I think it should have the
ability to audit the data owner and then
in a privacy-preserving way but here
actually privacy preserving in terms of
how the data owner is using it being
able to kind of do some notion of
verifiable computation as to how your
data is used so in other words to give
some actual interactive agency I have no
idea this is a great idea or not this is
the kind of thing I'm currently thinking
about the other part of that would be on
your device or the kind of the source
that gives that information build again
keep on pushing on human factors in this
setting and making sure that you
actually are having a conversation about
your own information that is that is an
informed conversation right so that's
the kind of second so it's either we cut
off the data or we enable we give you
more agency at the site of the actual of
the information itself so those are the
two areas that I've been thinking about
I think I have grabbed my ten minute
mark and so really I want to encourage
either you know questions on this but
either kind of moving forward from here
I really you know please do reach out to
me I've got a little bit of time to
figure out what this program should be
um one of the cool prerogatives of this
job is like so people come to me like Oh
what are you doing and my answer is
often like what do you think I should be
doing you know like I'm not the expert
in you know the stuff you know you know
tell me tell me you know what am I
missing what's possible what's possible
that I didn't know is possible and how
can we and how can we leverage that to
like build this you know to help help
folks so anyhow that's a that's what
we're doing Thanks
[Applause]
so if you talk about cutoff date
entirely and one thing that somebody
wants is it there's sort of also a civil
rights issue there and the access issue
in the my Davis disappears entirely then
I'm not represented in the data where
people decide what products should be
designed what services should be
provided and so on so you kind of once
kind of with the general services to
know that me and people like me exist
with the needs that I have but not know
that it's me specifically that's true I
mean I was talking it relates to a
different I was talking to a political
scientist at UC San Diego and she was
pointing out that a I specifically like
things like AI enabled social social
services also become in and of
themselves a another means to which our
third harrion regimes can like in a
backhanded way like do shifty things and
so I think it's kind of the two sides
that's quite up there there should be a
certain verifiability to all of it right
so these underlying any so yeah I think
it's
nice point yeah I
loosen invitees get here with the a is
piracy agent and I think you had
something like that in one of the early
science ways a privacy manager what's
inside that box I mean you're following
Helen immediately clear that to measure
them you know what the person's
expectations are what they know so it's
incredibly difficult yep so far have you
seen convincing implementation of those
that trying to on the fly right privacy
policies so I think you're absolutely
right
so essentially all of that work for us
is happening at Carnegie Mellon we're
finding a substantial number of the
academics that Carnegie Mellon who work
on issues of human factors so there are
kind of multiple parts of that we're
doing a lot of human factors experiments
and I was really hoping to show you some
of the designs but I actually don't have
a really good screenshot of what it is
and we're still experimenting so an
example is well first of so many
different dimensions this problem what
is the actual thing I ought to be
presenting you as a choice right so is
it like do you have access to this
location it actually turns out or should
this app have access to this location it
actually turns out that one of the more
powerful access mechanisms is actually
asking about third-party libraries that
are running on software so it's a little
bit more abstract from it from a user's
perspective but they're basically like
their research has shown it's something
like three or four different software
libraries that if they're running those
it there you like those applications are
running like us like are clocking
substantially more about you than
otherwise and so turning off print
specifically AdMob actually would be one
of the main ones which is again there's
issues of nudging and so we're studying
nudging within the context of this we're
studying whether if I tell you do you
want to do this particular thing ten
percent of your friends have done it or
ten percent of users have done it one
way versus ninety
the other way if that's more powerful so
that's a long way of saying I actually I
don't know and that's why we're
researching it and I wouldn't I wouldn't
pretend to say that we have an answer
but it's certainly of high interest us
particularly in the mobile doing
mine's less of a cancer cure your call
for idea the more it's the question
about the examples of work you showed
under current Brandeis were less tightly
or they seemed less tightly coupled to
each other then the picture I had in my
head of how these programs are are
structured and so could you say a little
bit about about that and how you know
how much is it may you know many teams
all sort of working on yeah yeah that's
it's so it is highly program specific
there is no one template Brandeis
frankly is a little unique normally we
have one integrator the way to think of
it here is we have three different
integrators my understanding is the way
this literally happened was they all
showed up on the first kickoff day and
it was like work to figure out groups
and work together now
and it worked that really shouldn't have
worked but it seems to have and I great
credit to a lot of our so again just to
back up so it's just easier to see what
I would say is that in there okay
essentially speaking especially in the
TA one domain they just like working as
you probably appreciate I'm just showing
the applicability of this technology is
so exciting that if you kind of present
people with art would you be willing to
extend yourself to a different
application space I know you've been
working on mobile but we have this issue
in coalition like is this interesting to
you and your answer is almost always yes
so that that's been really awesome
but Brandeis is pretty unique in this
structure race has been a lot more
single integrator a lot of different
performers will see what flies by whoa
so the zero knowledge one sorry I call
it five proofs using hidden information
we'll see if that name sticks is I can't
imagine it to be multiple multiple so a
lot of a lot of people developing NP
statements a lot of people doing
compilers and kind of mixing and
matching to see how it plays but we'll
see
and so I can't I you know so that's also
much more to speak six one fundamental
research so it's not really designed the
point there isn't to build working
for say it's more existence fruits this
is the kind of thing we can do
Brandeis was really intended to be like
this integration build actual prototypes
so yeah it's that's a really long way of
saying it really really depends
[Applause]